Ahhh...ça fait du bien !
Aujourd'hui, c'est la Journée mondiale de l'eau.
L'eau est le principal constituant
de notre organisme.
Le corps d'un adulte en contient 65 %.
Sur les 70 kg qui s'affichent chaque matin
sur ma balance, il y a 45 kg d'eau.
Ce liquide nous est vital.
Il y en a dans tous nos tissus jusque dans nos dents.
Mais comme nous sommes de véritables passoires,
toute cette eau ressort en effet
sous forme d'urine, de transpiration
y compris dans l'air que nous expirons.
Et bien, nous devons
refaire le plein en permanence.
2 litres par jour. 1/2 litre dans la nourriture et le reste
en buvant une douzaine de verre d'eau comme celui-ci.
De la bonne eau du robinet.
On n'a pas tous cette chance !
A votre santé et je vous le souhaite très sincèrement.
A demain et surtout n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes tous confinés
mais on reste en lien.
Si vous avez aimé cette "capsule de déconfiné"
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu.
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne pas les rater,
abonnez-vous et activez la cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...